هذا وكان حاكم مدينه سيباستيو بالقد اعلن
ان القوات الروسيه اسقطت امس طائرتين
مسيرتين في البحر قرب المدينه الواقعه في
شبه جزيره القرم كما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
كورستك الروسيه المحذيه لاوكرانيا ان
مسيره اوكرانيه استهدفت مطار مدينه قوسك
واتهمت روسيا القوه الاوكرانيه بتكثيف
الهجمات بالمسيرات على مطارات داخل
اراضيها
ولا الجيش الاوكرانيه القوه الروسيه تركز
هجومها على بخمه الشرقيه اوكرانيا وقد
نفذت خلال الساعات الماضيه ثلاثا 33 ضربه
جويه وخمسه وسبعين هجوما من انظمه صاروخيه
على مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه المنتشره على
طول خطوط التماس واضاف الجيش الاوكرانيه
ان القوه الروسيه تواصل قصفها مقاطعات
خرسا وسفالوجيا ومكرو لايف واذنبا ودمر
منازل عده في مدينه اكرام تورسك شرقيه
البلاد واضاف ان قوته صدت هجمات روسيه عده
على بعض المناطق التي لا تزال تحت سيطرته
في لوجان ودونيستك
ومعنى الاهلي
اذا تامر دعنا في صوره اخر التطورات من
فضلك
نعم ليله القصف متواصل منذ الليله الماضيه
وحتى ساعات فجر هذا اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظه
نحن نستمع لقصف متواصل متبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه هنا في حدود مقاطعه
زباروجيا السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول بان
العديد من القرى الواقعه ضمن سيطرتها
تعرضت للقصف هذه المره بصواريخ اس 3
الروسيه بالاضافه الى القصف المدفعي
المتواصل من قبل القوات الروسيه الحديثه
في صفوف المدنيين العديد من القرى الواقعه
على خط التماسنه في زباروج افرغت بالكامل
من السكان وتقول السلطات المحليه العسكريه
هنا في المدينه بان القوات الاوكرانيه
ايضا تقصف من تكثف من قصفها بشكل عنيف منذ
الليله الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه على مدينه
ميليتوبيل الواقعه في ريف زمولوجيا
الجنوبي حيث تسيطر القوات الروسيه على
امهم ذلك الريف وتقول بانها تسعى الى
الايقاع بالمدينه لانها تعتبر خط امداد
خلفي للمنطقه التي تتواجد فيها المحطه
محطه الطاقه النوويه في زبروجه والتي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه في الحقيقه
التطورات ليلى في عموم المقاطعات الجنوبيه
والتطورات ايضا الميدانيه على الارض في
المناطق الشرقيه في خرسون جنوبا تقول
السلطات بان القوات الروسيه ايضا كتفت من
قصفها للبنيه التحتيه ولمواقع تمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه وللعديد من القرى
والبلدات الواقعه على خطوط التماس وفي
المقابل تقول القوات الاوكرانيه بانها
كتفت من قصفها بالمدفعيه لمواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الاخرى منها
دينيبر والحديث ايضا عن قصف روسي متواصل
لمنطقه اشتوكه التي تتواجد فيها محطات
المياه التي تغذي مقاطعه ميكو لايف في
المياه حتى
الاخيره كانت السلطات الاوكرانيه تحديدا
قياده عمليات الجنوب تقول بان القصف
متواصل على اتشوكو وتتحدث ايضا عن قصف
ايطالي مدينه دنبرو مدينه دنبرو مقاطعه
الدين برو وسط جنوبي البلاد تتعرض وفقا
للقوات الاوكرانيه لقصف متواصل منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى الحديث عن عديد المناطق
وتحديدا مدينه كريفيري تتعرض للقصف في هذه
الاثناء بالاضافه الى منطقه نيبل الواقعه
ضمن حدود دينيبرو والقريبه ايضا من محطه
الطاقه النوويه في زبرود جاء تتعرض لقصف
مدفعي متواصل وفقا ل همم ما جاء على لسان
همم الجيش الاوكراني وبتاكيد التطور
اللافت والمتواصل شرقا هو في باتجاه مدينه
بخموت القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها وصلت
صدها طيله الليله الماضيه وحتى هذه
الساعات لمحاولات تقدم من قبل القوات
الروسيه تقول بانها تصد هذه المحاولات
وتتحدث عن قصف متواصل للعديد من المناطق
الواقعه تحت سيطرتها في لوجانس وفيدونيت
اشكرك تامر الصمادي على كل هذه المعلومات
فيما تعلق طبعا بالوضع الميداني شكرا لك
من سبوجيا